How's it going bros?
My name is PewDiePie
Today, I have some special exciting news
you've read the title,
I've finally,
FINALLY (laughs),
received the ten million diamond play button.
If you don't know,
YouTube is handing out, for people with over 10-million-subbed channels,
This diamond play button.
We are at 44 million!
So...it's a little late to the party YouTube!
But I thought we'd unbox this together.
*laugh*
I'm so excited!
*music stops*
Is this some kinda joke?
"Congratulations for surpassing a hundred thousand."
"Congrats for a hundred thousand subscribers."
Are you fucking kiddin' me?!
*bad ass music* DO YOU THINK THIS IS SOME KINDA GAME?!?
WHAT IS THIS SHIT?
A HUNDRED K?!
I get that fucking shit FOUR TIMES in a month!!
They announced this shit years ago.
FOUR YEARS AGO!
What the fuck?!
Why don't you give me 440 of these?
Yeah, give one to Jimmy Fallon!
Give one to DiamondMinecraft!
Ya, give one to Kwebbelkop!
EVEN iDUBBBZ!?
What is this?
The fuck is this?!
Who the hell is that guy!?!
ER....yeah, give one to ERB!
And give one to Smosh!
Fucking bullshit!
*Sad music starts* I ain't doin' this shit anymore, YouTube.
I'm fuckin' tired!
Here I was, thinkin' for once, my effort had been recognized.
I was so happy!
*Sad music stops* What's that?
Another package?!
*Dramatic music starts*
Could this be...?
The fuck is this!?
What does it say?
*bad ass music* IT'S THE 1 MILLION ONE!!
AND IT'S FUCKING BROKEN!!
"Congrats for surpassing 1 million."
Oh, that's cool!
THAT HAPPENED YEARS AGOOO!
GIVE ME 44 OF THESE!!!
That's it, YouTube!
I had enough of your bullshit.
I'm calling you out right now:
Where's my diamond play button?
And I'm not gonna do a fucking hashtag,
and make all my fans tweet at you
Send it to YouTube.
It's about goddamn time.
Are you listening, Youtube?
These are my demands:
1) I want FOUR
diamond play buttons!
2) I want them delivered by a horse.
3) I want them smothered in glitter.
Not too much,
make it classy.
4) I want the man delivering the packages
to be a bearded, beautiful man.
5) And I want a written apolog-
I want you to-
I want a BEGGED apology!
Alright!
But for real though,
ehm,
(classic PDP laughter)
I can't believe it's broken!
What the fuck!
Jesus!
Good job FedEx!
You fuckin' idiots,
you fucked up!
Like, what I'm gonna-
This is clearly trash!
Like, what am I gonna do with it?
I'm legit pissed!
UHAUWHUAHUWAH
I waited so long!
And I..you know what?
I thought-
okay, once they announced the diamond play button,
two years ago,
I was like,
"Oh that's cool,
maybe now I'll finally get it."
*Sad music plays*
Alright!
Alright bros!
Go forth!
Send out the hashtag!
I want that shit trending
on Twitter,
Facebook,
Tumblr,
Harass them anywhere.
Instagram!
I don't give a fuck!
This ends now!
If I don't have my YouTube play button,
within a month,
then I'll...I..I'll
I'll do something, alright?
I'll do something...
REAL BAD YOUTUBE!
You're gonna make, uh
youWICJWIECJIWJCWIOCW
THIS MEANS WAR, YOUTUBE!
THIS
MEANS
WAR!
Dont make me disappointed
Not again